- [Interviewer] There have been
times that you've been told
that you don't have a
ballet dancer's body.
- Mmhmm.
- Is that true?
- I mean, to this day I
still hear it. (laughs)
It scarred me.
It's made me hate myself.
There have been so many levels
of feelings and transitions
of being on your own at 17
years old in New York City,
and trying to figure out
who you are as a person,
and fit into this world, and
being told that, you know,
it took me a long time to understand
what these people were saying.
- [Interviewer] What were they saying?
- That you have brown
skin and you don't belong,
and that's why you don't
have the right body,
because I know that I have a similar body
to a lot of professional dancers.
And to this day, professional
dancers are much more athletic
than they used to be.
And they have busts and they have hips.
And if those dancers are
white, they're not criticized
for the same thing.
And so, it took me some time
to accept and realize that,
and try and decipher those words.
But yeah, to this day I can go on a blog,
and read that I have the most
hideous body and I'm fat.
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
So you know, it's about
understanding people's intentions,
not reading those things,
and just you know,
trusting in yourself and doing the work,
and being your healthiest self,
and that was a big part
of creating this book,
Ballerina Body, was that
it's not about transforming
and making yourself
look like someone else,
or look like Gelsey
Kirkland or Sylvie Guillem.
It's not about that, it's about
being your healthiest self,
and making your body
the best that it can be.
And that's what I've learned
throughout my journey
as a professional dancer.